- Gotta pee.
- What?
- You want to go pee real quick, now?
- I'm gonna hold it in.
- For real?
- That should be how you actually start
the episode that way.
♫ Me and Gary Vee up in the office
♫ Do rag flappin'
walkin' through corporate
♫ Talks about all this shit been leveraged
♫ 1,800 texts and shout out the beverage
- [Gary] All right, let's do this again.
Now this time, we're
gonna, oh there's AJ, AJV.
You gonna call?
AJ on a Vayner sports call.
That was exciting.
Always good to see my bro.
All right let's go downstairs.
Downstairs is where Pure Wow is.
If you're not subscribe
to purwow.com right now.
Taylor, can you put the link
right here for purewow.com?
That is where this is.
Hey!
- Hey, how are you?
- I'm super well, how are you?
- Good.
- [Gary] Good.
- You're filming?
- [Gary] Yeah, I'm just
doing a little filming.
Fuck it, why not.
Let's see what's going on down here.
That's Pure Wow over there.
Hey, Lisa Buckley!
- Hi!
- [Gary] How are you?
- Good, good, how are you?
- [Gary] Well?
I'm super well, hey dude.
Wow, you're hair is
legit, I really like that.
- [Man] What's up, Gary?
- [Gary] What's up, man.
You guys like his hair?
(laughing)
I like it.
Hey, man, how are you?
- Hi.
This is Pure Wow.
Just show you something really quick.
This Ryan Harwood when
he was 30 pounds lighter,
but he's still a CEO,
so it didn't affect him.
The extra weight didn't
affect him and his ability
to be the CEO of Pure Wow.
We are, rare opportunity where
DRock or Iris or Justin are
not around, and I'm in
the office by myself.
So, let's get a little bit of a tour.
This is the Quiet Riot
room, for all you '80s kids.
There's Quiet Riot.
That's it.
There's a couple, I don't
know what the hell is going
in here now.
There used to be a big ass table here,
but something's going on.
Let's see what's going on here.
- Holy shit, holy shit, holy shit.
Hey!
- That's right, Shirley.
Glad I caught that.
- [Shirley] Hey, great.
- Amazing, hey.
Make sure that's huge
and everybody sees it.
- And I beat everybody.
I don't know.
♫ They say you don't gotta go
home but you can't stay here
♫ And though I don't wanna be
alone in the world out there
- Let me actually show
you around a little bit,
since the first time you're here.
And then we'll come back.
♫ They say you don't gotta go
home but you can't stay here
♫ And though I don't wanna be alone
- It's right here.
♫ In the world out there
♫ They say you don't gotta go
home but you can't stay here
♫ And though I don't wanna be
alone in the world out there
♫ They say you don't gotta go home
- I have one skill.
- I like your approach.
- I really understand people.
In my will, in my active
will, it says if the human
race figures out how to
measure emotional intelligence
I wanna be scored.
That's how deeply I feel it
came to me at a genius level,
but we don't talk about that.
The only people that make the
move care about one thing.
Legacy.
If you do not care about
legacy, you don't trade
on this moment in time.
Andy?
Babbin?
DRock?
I've got it figured out.
(upbeat piano music)
- Here, I'm gonna sit.
- Hi!
- Sounds awesome.
The practicality of
I'm gonna learn a craft
this summer is ludicrous,
'cause there's too many things
that are not in control of
that being the situation,
hence why I think it's
about the people, and plus,
in reality, anything you
would learn in six or eight
or 10 weeks, you're gonna
learn in the first 90 days
of a job.
At this point, where you're
questioning everything
and so many of you are still in that place
where you're just checking
the box of what the right
thing to do is, because
that's how you've been trained
for the last 20 years of
your life, this is exactly
the time to start debating it, for real.
Because you wake up and
you're 32 real quick.
(laughing)
Right?
This is Eric Castner.
He helped me build Wine Library.
We were just sitting in a
small cubical five seconds ago,
building this website,
so it happens real quick.
- [Woman] How do you stay
focused on your own path
and success without comparing
yourself to other people
or not listening to anybody
else's opinion of you?
- I don't know.
Combination of being an immigrant
and having a ridiculously
big time mom.
Because I don't.
And it's so real.
I really wish you could have it, too.
God, confidence, right?
Just not wavering.
Just fundamentally not caring
about what anybody else thinks
or feeling that anybody else
is impacting me besides myself.
But that's what I will do to the end.
So.
Thanks, guys.
Thanks, everyone.
(clapping)
- How are you?
- Really good, how are you, my friend?
Real pleasure.
- I was the first black stand-up
comedian in South Africa.
- [Gary] Really?
- About 19 years ago.
Almost every black comic from
South Africa, I found them,
or I put them on my show.
I've got a show called The
Blacks Only Comedy Show
which has been going
on for about 13 years.
- [Gary] Incredible.
- So coming here now, it's a bit like--
- [Gary] It's fun, I get--
- I can just book a theater,
but then, I'm not gonna be
part of the system--
- [Gary] I got it, I got it.
- I kinda need to get into that--
- [Gary] Social.
- Yeah.
- Fast.
- You know what you need to do?
You need to call in every favor.
If you take a picture
every single goddamn day,
with some comedian who has
10,000, 50,000, 100,000,
40,000, five million, 100,000, a million.
If you just do it
everyday, it will matter.
And then, if you, in between
that, make good content,
you're on your way.
And that part comes easy
to you, 'cause you're
a successful comedian.
(hip hop music)
- Thanks for making happen.
I mean I would've done anything.
Thanks, man.
- No doubt.
- Real pleasure.
- Thank you so much.
- Let's stay in touch.
DM me anytime.
- [Man] This is the fire from (mumbling).
- Love it.
Hi.
- Hi, I'm Jordan, nice to meet you.
- Jordan, I'm Gary, nice to meet you.
- Hey Gary.
Good to see you.
- Good to see you again.
How are you?
- I've heard so much
about you.
- I'm good, man.
- Good man.
- The coolest thing about your
impact on the world right now
and I said it in the email
is that here's a guy,
23 years of school, three
graduate degree, right?
Orthodontist.
As pro-school as there is out
there, telling his daughter
when she comes back from a
week-long program in Louisville
to figure out what your
future is, she somebody speak
about social media
branding, and I say to her,
if social media branding is what you want,
and that's where you wanna go, intern.
Go somewhere and learn the business.
Don't go to college.
And she's fighting me,
I wanna go to college.
And I'm like, you're not going to college.
(laughing)
- It's like this bizarro world.
She's like, Dad, college is fun.
- Yes, that's what I said.
- She's like I want a sorority.
So, I'm like, I'm gonna go
find a bunch of good looking
girls, pay them money to take you--
- To hang out?
I love it.
- That's like a hashtag,
like the Gary Vee affect.
- But you know what's funny
about that, or she could do
college the way I did,
which is actually understand
that truth, have fun in her
sorority, what have you,
but in the time that
would've been study hours,
hone her craft.
She could kind of go to
college and, there's a version,
you've gotta go to a shitty
enough college, this is
just the truth, where you
can actually have a job,
and have college life.
Like some colleges will kick
you outta school, right?
Some won't.
I went there.
(laughing)
Like I literally went to
four classes in my life.
- So, the key is she needs to
go to a shitty enough college.
- Shitty enough college
that you can still get
the college experience,
but you have eight hours
a day to actually work on
the, you could have four years
of getting great at social
by literally working.
If you go to Ohio State,
working at some Columbus, Ohio,
small agency, like nine to
five, should be going to class.
Now, Ohio State will probably
kick you out, but this is
literally my thesis on this.
- This is like one of those
millions of conversations
that now you've created
in homes that didn't exist
before you--
- I get it, man.
I get it.
- It was weird, I never
though my dad would say--
- [Gary] You were like, what
are you talking about, Dad.
- And I was a crappy student.
- [Gary] And where are you, now?
Like a sophomore, junior?
Where are you in high school?
- I'm gonna be a senior.
- You're gonna be a senior?
- Yeah.
♫ I'm gonna be a legend
♫ I'm gonna be a Jonny to your daddy
♫ Outside news
♫ Ordinary people
staying going going crazy
♫ For an outlier
♫ I'm gonna kiss ya like you busy missy
♫ Be my cherry putting out fires
♫ See, I ain't never running from a rebel
♫ Only if I got my cramp under
♫ Minor is my word
♫ My bark is my bite, girl
♫ My co-world, my lips, girl
♫ Love your curl, love your words
♫ Seein' as I'm leaving now or later
♫ Love me longer, longer for you my dear
♫ Bein' we believin', I'm lay awakin'
♫ Even when I didn't, baby I swear
- Bottom line is we've
really figured it out.
Like I really know what to do.
You could become unbelievably
recognized every time
you walk around Portland, in
a way that would stun you.
I don't know what else to say.
It's basically, think of
it more like Lucille Ball
and Bob Hope, when radio
went to television,
the world still thought
a radio star was bigger
than a television star,
but it wasn't true.
And it took about a decade
for people to be like fuck.
That's basically.
Logan and Jake Paul are
way more famous to anybody
under 25 than virtually every
other person you can name.
That's it.
- You think about it?
I just saw a headline said one
piece of content can change
it all, no seriously.
Tim Ferris wrote one book
that literally launched
the entire career.
You've got two or three videos--
- Even better, bro, even
better, bro, to your point,
that keynote I gave at the
Javits Center at Web 2.0,
then went on YouTube on TED
Talk, changed my career.
- Yeah.
- Led to Crush It.
You know, it's one piece of content.
But if you have brand equity,
but if you have brand equity,
you will be fine.
There is never a bad
time when you believe,
when you work hard and when
you know what you're doing.
But you have to do, this
is where it's crucial,
you have to do what you love, because let
me tell you something.
It gets tough, but if you
love it, you will win.
The only way to succeed now is
to be completely transparent.
Completely.
Everything is exposed, everything you do.
So, your legacy is your ultimate life.
It's all you've got, and you
can build so much on that.
When you have brand equity,
anything can happen.
Written word, audio, video, pictures.
Four forms of communication
have the ability to do 'em all.
I mean, it's the best job on earth.
It's literally what every single
14 year old on earth wants
to either be a YouTube
star or an influencer.
Like why wouldn't you live
your life and make money?
These are fuckin' hot!
I have so many cool sneaks.
Who's a 10 1/2 around here?
Who?
(mumbling)
You are?
(rustling and chatting)
I don't think I'll wear these.
You want these?
Bang.
You're a 10 1/2?
- [Man] No.
- What are you big, you a 12?
Yeah, I got it, I nailed it, I nailed it.
I'm good at guessing people's shoe size.
That's a random skill that
people don't realize I have.
Oh, so you're really
trying to be a winner?
- Yes.
- I'm proud of you, man.
- So you go in here--
- This is fuckin' rad.
So, why don't we take it,
don't spend the money so fast.
For example, that, we
should take two interns,
literally just DM every
single fuckin' Facebook
culture page and pay
them just to share it.
- Yeah.
- What need to do is
replicate something, starting
with Vayner, this is
back to my intern idea.
We need to have a slush fund of people.
The way I roll, the right
model is there's five
guys and girls on our team
that actually don't have
anything to do other than
the thing of the moment
until I take them off
the thing of the moment.
Like right now, if I had
four people, think about who
they have to be.
They have to be more
of our cloth, which is,
they have to be completely,
utterly not fancy
and have to be willing
to eat shit and be like,
for example, back in the
day, when me and AJ launched
prelees dress me, the
search engine, the tshirt
search engine, the best
thing I did, the thing I was
most fun was staying up to
five in the morning DMing
people or whatever that was at the time.
Email blogs randomly.
I think it's cool to now, I'm
gonna weirdly start sending,
once Z's up to date,
Tyler's gonna, I think it's,
and I don't care who does it...
To me, nothing's smarter
right now than spending
15 hours messaging every
Facebook that has a million
followers that's a culture
page and be like hey,
we have a video we'd like you to share.
How much?
Control C, Control V, listen
to your favorite fuckin'
album 50, like I can't wait
for my vacation in August
to do that.
I just wanna remind you guys
that that's probably why
my Instagram and podcast
work, 'cause I went
on vacation, did that a
little bit and was like
this is what we.
We need to figure out how
to hire and how to frame up
for people to realize
that's the best thing to do,
not oh, wait a minute,
I'm a film maker or I'm a
business development, or
like you know what I mean?
We need unbelievable amounts of humility
to get done the kind of
things I most believe in,
'cause what I most believe in
is all these people right now,
I just want to basically
DM people on Facebook.
This is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 260
of the Ask Gary Vee Show.
And I'm super fired up.
All right, Linda, tell
everybody who you are.
- [Linda] All right, the two cents.
Here's the two cents.
- Three cents.
- Three cents, okay.
- Legends get three cents.
- Okay, nobody has hosted
more Sports Centers than me
on ESPN.
- Okay, hold on.
Let's just say that one more time.
- All right, nobody, male
or female, has hosted more
Sports Centers on ESPN
than me, Linda Cohn.
All right.
- Thank you so much.
- All right, Gary.
- You keep asking question,
we'll keep answering them.
- [Linda] Awesome.
- On this episode, LFC stops by!
You have a good day?
- Oh, hell yeah.
- [Man] An hour and a half might work.
- Bye.
- Bye, Gary.
- Good?
- [Man] Good, Gary!
(electronic music)